alright let's try going to our caller
from the eighth 1/8 area code listen for
your area code caller from 8 1 8 are you
there can you hear me yeah I believe so
I believe so a little Dave how are you
good go ahead
good good well first of all my name is
John I'm calling from Kong from Los
Angeles and yeah I appreciate you I
appreciate you taking calls and I
appreciate your show you know there's
certainly things that where I imagine we
well I agree with you and disagree with
you on certain points contemporary and
historical but go on you always seem but
you generally seem to be a guy who tries
to get things right and as opposed to
maybe just getting quicksand I I
appreciate that
about you Mike my general question for
you in now I'm a person I'm a registered
Republican but I mean I've got a you
know I've got a long history of engaging
politics on both sides of the aisle both
professionally and personally and so
forth and my big concern is trying to
create sort of a culture of
understanding that allows people to
communicate in such a way that sort of
allows for action or political progress
John I hate to interrupt but you're
killing me here what what's your
question today I got 12 you're holding
and I want to get a difference sure so
much so my question for you is how
important do you think it is for us to
sort of focus on impacting the culture
of politics on a retail level so people
can communicate with each other more
effectively or do you think that that's
sort of an overly idealistic way to try
and engage the political process it's
very idealistic but I think it's a
worthwhile endeavor and I believe and
and you know I think that there we when
you look at who's taking critical
thinking out of classrooms it's not the
left right so I think that both sides
know that if you build up that
infrastructure that fosters sort of
incisive and critical thinking that it
favors one side politically and it's not
the American right so I actually believe
that the American right is
disincentivized to try to create that
infrastructure of thinking that I think
culture
would be so good for us well you know I
imagine that there are ways in which
there might be true particularly if
you're talking about potentially
something like climate science or
whatnot and I know that your audience
probably means mostly mostly left so you
won't get a lot of pushback on that
observation but as a matter of kind of
bringing all sides to the table in the
most powerful possible way it is it is
it possible for us to try and frame
things in a way that doesn't immediately
polarize people along the axis of left
and right in our sort of popular
political dialogue or they're just
inevitable that everything has to be
framed along or left right well let's
let's play it out I mean give me an
example of an issue that is a polarized
issue and tell me how you would frame it
in order to get the left and right
talking in a more productive way sure
yeah so uh let's say a healthcare for
instance you've got people with
dramatically different orthodoxies with
respect to what they think healthcare
policy ought to be if I'm having a
conversation with a person on the right
or on the left I try to I try to come at
it by framing it in terms of saying okay
I know you think that the system works
better there's a free market or you know
government-run sort of program where we
can start off agreeing is that everybody
ought to have access whether through
government guarantee or just do
affordable prices and so forth everybody
ought to have access to health care
because without access to health care
the guarantee to really liberty the
pursuit of happiness and life itself
yeah but the problem is John you're not
that's not going to work because not
everybody believes that your your
appreciate what you're doing which is
trying to find some basis we could all
start with as an agreement and then try
to figure out how to get there but there
are people on the right who
fundamentally disagree with what you're
saying not not everybody does have a
right to have a basic level of health
care according to many people on the
right it's not just a question of sort
of methods but it's also a question of
what what even our fundamental
understanding is so I think is much more
difficult than that I would love to do
it I think the critical thinking would
be a great
way to sort of start having that
conversation and I John are you still
there okay we looks like we lost John
but in any case I think it's much more
difficult than maybe John is uh will
willing to say there but it sounds great
to me let's see if we can figure out how
to do it